I know it's early in the year, but we're already talking about our summer family trip. And you know we like to Airbnb. I know this. Well, we like to have a kitchen and I like to be able to walk out in my robe in the morning and have a cup of tea and as you call it, Jenna, I like a long runway. Yes. Well, you know, Lee is working in Oklahoma right now and we're going to come out to visit him and he got us a really nice Airbnb to stay in as a whole family. So that we could spread out, and everybody could sleep well. And then you feel like you're at home,
even though you're in a different city. Lady, I don't wanna sleep in the same room as my whole family. That's why I can't do hotels great anymore. Yeah, cause you all bunk up, and share a bathroom. Yeah, I like the space. I like a refrigerator, a real refrigerator. I like to have snacks, as you know. I do know this. Yes, correct. I don't want to call room service. I want them right there. That's right. Yeah. Everyone, we're ladies who Airbnb, I guess, for your next adventure, for your next
vacation, maybe consider Airbnb. With the Fizz loyalty program you get rewarded just for having a mobile plan. You know, for texting and stuff. And if you're not getting rewards like extra data and dollars off with your mobile plan, you're not with Fizz. Switch today. Conditions apply. Details at fizz.ca. Friday Chit Chat with Jenna and Angela and Cassie and Sam. Hey! It's Friday Chit Chat with the office ladies folks. Woohoo!
Hi everybody. Welcome to Friday Chit Chat. Welcome to Friday Chit Chat. We've got a few things to chat about. We were feeling chatty today and we thought, why don't we make a whole bonus moment out of it. I feel like this is going to be, if we keep it going, the sort of kind sister to office ladies burn it to the ground. Oh, you think Friday Chit chat gets a little spicy? I'm just saying it's off the cuff.
It's whatever we're thinking and feeling. Yeah, I have no idea what you're about to say to me. No idea. It's that soothing balm you apply after the burn of? Office ladies burn it to the ground? Yep. Well, eventually, we're just going to come on here as cranky old ladies and burn it to the ground.
But right now, we're still feeling a little positive, right? A little peppy with our Friday chit chat. Exactly. Can I tell you guys how my day started as I came into our building? Yeah, please go. Okay, you know how you try to get everything on one trip so you're carrying multiple things?
Because God forbid you make two trips to the car, you know what I mean? Well, to be fair, where we park is a bit of a trek. It's a bit of a trek so I have like my laptop, my bag, I have my little office ladies coffee tumbler mug thing and Josh calls me and then I got my phone in the crook of my neck and I'm holding these things and I'm trying to hit the elevator button in the building. Yeah. But like I'm all jammed up and the superintendent of our building goes, hey, hey, hey, come in my elevator. He's like, hey, hey, I'm already in here.
I'm like, oh, okay. And I pop in. This building has how many floors? 12? I think. I pop in and I'm already running a little late. He's got every single button lit up. No. And he's on a walkie talkie and I'm like, what's happening?
And Josh is like, where are you? I'm like, I'm in an elevator, babe. And then he's like, we're testing the elevators today. So we're stopping at every floor. Did he think this would be what you wanted? I don't know. And I was like, what? He was like, hey, lady, in a rush, holding lots of stuff.
I've got a treat for you. I know. You want to stop at every floor with me? And so I was like, Josh, I got to go. And then I said, I need to get off this elevator. And he was like, oh, he goes, I go, he said, what floor are you? And when I told him my floor number, he goes, oh, I'm so sorry. Yeah.
So then I got off at level two, which I've never been on in this building. And is it special or different? Yeah. How did it compare? It looked just the same, but a fella had his door open. You know, all of our doors are closed. We go in our office, we shut the door. Yeah.
I don't see it. What was inside? I love an open door. I love an open, I'm so sorry to say, if you live in a house and you have your curtains open, I'm going to look in your house. Are you a peeper? When you're taking a walk, do you look into people's houses too? Especially if it's nighttime and there's light coming from the house? Yeah, I want to see what are you watching on TV? Are you cooking dinner? What's
your routine? I'm for it. What was in the door, Angela? A man. A man what? A very tall man. He was sitting down and my first thought was like, his chair is too small for him. Okay. He needs, or it's too low. I'm like, this is a tall man sitting kind of in a little chair. I don't know him. I don't know if I'll ever see him again,
but I'm gonna wonder about him in his chair. It's gonna be hard for me not to stop on the second floor on the way out today. See if his door's open. I'm picturing you in a being John Malkovich situation. Mm. Yeah, yeah. So that was the energy I brought in this morning and I was like, Jenna, you and I,
she was like, save it for Friday Chit Chat. I've got another question for you, lady. Okay. For Friday Chit Chat. Do you wanna share your beef with Ben Stiller? Oh no. Yes. Yeah, lay it on her.
Oh no you guys. I don't know him at all. I'm sure he's a lovely person. I know him well and I love him and he is a lovely person. Okay. Well, I guess they're doing the Severance podcast in our same studio, right? We found this out. They are.
Ben Stiller and Adam Scott have a Severance podcast. Yes. And they record it in our studio. And every time we come in to record now, my headphones don't fit me. They're so big. You've decided that the reason they're big is because Ben Stiller is widening them for his head. And this is like, this sounds so mean. But every time I put them on, they don't fit. I'm like, damn it, Ben and your big head. And then I have to readjust them. Ben, I don't
know if your head is big. I just, your hair is a little poofy. So I, I'm assuming the headphones have to fit over your poofy hair Also, I feel like Adam Scott's head is much bigger That's gotta be Adam Scott. I know why are we blaming it on Ben? Oh, I don't know cuz his hair's so poofy My hair is poofy and I have a regular size head. I don't know one of them has a big head I don't know one of them sits in my seat. But I hear great things about Sepphras. You haven't seen it? No, Josh has watched it and he wants me to watch it
with him, but I haven't watched it yet. Oh, I love it. Speaking of a whole world, I mean, you love whole worlds and like alternate realities. Josh said I would love it. He wants me to start watching it, but we have a few other things he wants me to watch. There's a queue.
Well, he really wanted me to watch Black Doves. Oh, I haven't heard of that. What is that about? It's so good. It might be Black Dove Singular. I don't know. You know how I do that. Sometimes I pluralize things.
We do. It's so good. It's got, Keira Knightley is in it. It is so good. It's got, Keira Knightley is in it. It is so good. It's a TV show? I'm obsessed, yes. It's set in the UK and I don't want to give too much away. It's really good.
She's phenomenal in it. I mean, I think Keira Knightley is all the sell I need. Yeah, but the whole cast is fantastic. Guess what I watched the beginning of the other day with my lunch. Oh, what did you watch on your lunch break? Did you not see the office lady's text thread? I'm already livid. I'm clenching my fists. Wait, I did see it. I didn't know you watched that on your lunch.
How did I miss that? That is not a lunch watch. Kat, thank you. What a random time to watch this. How did you watch that on your lunch? How did I miss that? That is not a lunch watch. Yes, thank you. What a random time to watch this. I knew the moment I was getting these texts, you were watching it while cleaning or doing something in the back. I knew the chances of you sitting down
with a blanket and a bucket of popcorn and pressing play were zero. Tell them. Tell them what you watched while having lunch. Lord of the Rings. Hey. How much did you watch? Yeah, how much?
15, 20 minutes? How long does it take you to eat your sandwich? It was a pasta. Oh. It was a factor meal, by the way. We're not sponsored by factor, but I think we should be, because I really like their food.
We would like to be. Um, I got to... Tell me the time code. I don't know. That Gandalf guy showed up in a wagon. That Gandalf. In a wagon? What?
Isn't that his name? He shows up to the Shire. Yes. Yes, that's his name. It's Gandalf. Yeah, and he talked to the... What's he do? What are you going to say?
Bo Bo Baggins? Bilbo. Bilbo. Yeah. What do you do? What are you going to say? Bobo Baggins? Bilbo. Bilbo. Bilbo. Bilbo Baggins. I also would have accepted Bobo Baggins. I like Bobo. This is like how you talked about Carl on Game of Thrones.
Here was my thing. Guys, I, oh no, embracing myself, Sam. Okay, what I texted on the text thread was like, I'm seven and a half minutes into this movie and all I have is just like a narrated backstory. You said there's a lot of talking. Montage of the lore. It's just like seven and a half minutes of lore which
again you're about to if you watched all three you're about to watch ten hours of Lord of the Rings you can handle seven minutes here's I need a lesson before the movie starts here she goes I am out I'm out like no can't this information be spread out through plot and conversation? It's being given to you by someone speaking it at the beginning. But a narrator, it's just a narration. And there's so much to remember. Do you realize how many people and lands
and like, these people don't like these people. And then I'm like, what's the difference between the, what are they elves, hobbits and the other people? And then the, I don't, oh. And then also like the ring just fell into the bottom of a lake and nobody looked for it for how long? We just let it sit there.
People have been looking for it for how long? We just let it sit there. People have been looking for it for a long time. And then that guy finds it just by happenstance, but it doesn't turn him evil. He just loses it again. What? Or the Baggins person finds it. It does turn him evil. It does turn him evil.
You have to watch if you watch more than 20 minutes of it. Okay, okay, okay, fine. Listen, I'm so sorry. People love Lord of the Rings. I might finish it because I will say after that part that I just was, you know, was like an itchy blanket to me that I was enduring. You hate learning new stuff about worlds.
Like, I just, you just hate it. And I'm gonna call bulls**t. It doesn't matter if it's in narration. It doesn't matter if characters are living it. You don't want to learn the new world. And yet I love Severance. Love it. Okay.
What's that? I don't know. What's the difference? But you're gonna stick with it, Lord of the Rings? You're gonna stick with it? I'm gonna stick with it because once the two people started talking to each other, they're such good actors. Yeah.
And now I'm interested. Now I'm sort of like, oh, what's going to happen now that he has this ring? I was intrigued. My precious. Oh, boy. Do you know what that means? I mean, I think Silence of the Lambs, but no.
Yes, it is Silence of the Lambs. Let's let her think that. That's exactly what it is. OK. There's a movie that crosses over with Silence of the Lambs. There's kind of a random guest star by Anthony Hopkins. Does anybody else have anything else to say for Friday Chit Chat?
I've been watching The Pit on HBO. It's Noah Weill is his name. It's like a procedural show, kind of like ER. But it's just really, really well done in the way, so like one season takes place over like two days in the hospital, so when one episode picks up, it's like right where it left off on the previous one. It's really, really well done and really, really fascinating.
We just started it. Okay. It's great. I've only seen the first episode and it's so good. Is it Noah Wiley? I think so. I think I said it wrong. He was on ER. Yeah. Yes. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Friends, I watched Love is Blind, Season 8.
Oh, nice. Wait, is Love is Blind... Again, I refuse to believe that your brain can handle Love is Blind and not Lord of the Rings. Thank you. It's in Love is Blind, it's kind of brain rot, isn't it? Is it like two people, oh no, people are gonna come for me now.
Oh no, it's brain rot. It's brain rot. It's okay. It is stimulating, intelligent television. It's intelligent television. No, it is people in pods, they can't see each other, they get mixed and matched on these blind dates, and then they have to fall in love
without ever seeing each other. Although my one complaint is, ultimately everyone's hot. There's not... The casting is like... You're not... There's not like a big chance that like you're not gonna be attracted to each other. I have a question. I have a question.
What? Because I haven't seen it. Is it... You said they go on blind dates, but they can't see each other? That's right. They get sequestered. I have a question. I don't know. I have a question. What? Because I haven't seen it. Is it, you said they go on blind dates, but they can't see each other? That's right. They get sequestered. So there's like a girl's dorm and a boy's dorm.
And then there's these pods. And you go into a pod and there's like a scrim between you. You each have a couch and you sit in there and you just have dates. And you can eat food and you chit chat And you talk about your lives and if you fall in love They open the scrim. No first you have to get engaged What you have to get engaged before they open the scrim? Oh, I hate they don't even open the scrim You just you get engaged then you see each other
Then you go on a honeymoon you go on a vacation together with all the other couples who got engaged. So now there's a bunch of hot people on a vacation. So and they've never touched. They've never touched. Never touched, but you're engaged. Yeah. I have another question. What?
When they go on this group. Vacation? Honeymoon? Yeah, it's like they go on a vacation and then after the vacation, they go back to their city of origin, and they live together. And then they get married in six weeks. Oh my god.
Oh, wow. Or not. This is so much. Or they don't get married. I have a question. What? When they go on this group honeymoon, is that what it is? Mm-hmm.
Yeah. So they're already married? No, they're just engaged. Oh, so they go on a group engagement vacation. Correct. And there's multiple pairs of newly engaged people who've never seen each other. Right, yes.
That travel together to a destination. And they're all attractive. Hook up? Well, some of them have been talking to other people and they're like, I thought I was gonna pick Angela, but I ended up getting engaged to Jenna. Now I see Angela. And I'm much more attracted to her if I'm being honest.
So then there's weird crossover and then shenanigans and hookups. You got it. With not the person you potted with. You got it, lady. Also, that is the exact amount of time it would have taken you to pay attention to Lord of the Rings. That amount of information.
It took seven minutes. Okay, touche, touche. I do have to play for you guys. My friend Nikki got me a birthday gift. Nikki and I watch Love is Blind together. Did she get you a cameo? She got me a cameo. My last birthday, she got me gold wine glasses. Because they only drink out of gold stemware.
I remember that, I remember that. Okay, this year, this is what I got from my friend Nikki. I hope they don't drink wine out of cold stemware. Hi Jenna, first of all, happy belated birthday. And I hear that this actually isn't just any birthday. It is a very special birthday because you just kicked cancer's ass. Yeah girl, you did that shit. Honestly, I can't think of anything more impressive.
That's definitely more impressive than surviving love is blind because I do actually know a thing or two about surviving really interesting situations to say the least. You are clearly so much stronger than any of the men that I had to deal with on Love is Blind which, let's be honest, the bar is in hell but real recognizes real. If anyone deserves to celebrate, it's you, Queen. So happy, happy birthday. I hope this next year brings you so much happiness, so much health, emotionally intelligent men, and supportive sisters. Bye. That was Madison, y'all. Oh, I don't know who she is, but I think that's a great, great message. Who is Madison? Is she the Gandalf of Lord of the Love is Blind?
Lord of Love is Blind. Lord of the Blind. I don't know, because I don't know what Gandalf's role is. He's the wizard. No, but she's just a super cool chick. I liked her message. Who's really rad, and I couldn't believe it. I responded to this cameo how I imagine any person responds to a cameo.
When she said my name, I was like, oh, this must be random. And then she's like, you kicked cancer's ass. I'm like, she's talking about me. Yeah, that's awesome. But she said the bar is hell. What does that mean? That means I think- The bar is so low.
The bar is so low. In the pods. Okay, well I had all of a sudden this flash that they have a bar with the theme of hell or something on the show. No, you've gone back to like Lord of the Rings. I did, I did. I went back.
You've gone back to fantasy. A show I'm watching right now is called Offline Love. Okay. It's a Japanese reality TV show, but it takes place in Nice, France. What? Yeah. Layers. Where do I watch this?
On Netflix. Okay. And it's five guys, five girls, single, and they just get dropped off in Nice and they don't have their phones. They just have a little guidebook for the town and they're exploring the town and they run into each other. And then they maybe go on dates and it just feels like fate because they're like away from home, they don't have cell phones.
How do they find each other? They just like happen to like walk into a thrift store and they see one of them holding the guidebook and they're like, oh my God, are you doing the show? And they're like, I am. And they're like, are you hungry? Do you want to go to a cafe together? That sounds so sweet.
It's like a shared experience. And being a fish out of water is what then kind of bonds them. Yeah, exactly. And then have you seen romances bloom? Starting to, yeah. OK, I think I could get more behind that than Love is Blind. Yeah, it's very like really no drama.
Oh, I like that. Yeah, it's making me really no drama. Oh, I like that. Yeah, it's making me want to go to France. Well, you get travel and then you get the kind of like love connection part too. Yeah, yeah. It's like when you go to like another city somewhere and you randomly run into someone you know and you get way more excited about seeing them in that city
than you probably would in your hometown. You're like, oh my god! Hey! Yes, you're right. We're both in Ohio! Oh my god, what are you doing in Ohio? I'm in Ohio! While we're on the topic of no drama love shows, has anyone seen Love on the Spectrum? Yes. That's an incredible show. We've talked about this on the pod, have we not? Oh really? Because you love it, Angela. I love it. And you know, I just, the pod, have we not? Oh, really? Because you love it, Angela. I love it.
And you know, I just, the parents, when the parents share, I just cry my eyes out. They're so proud of their kids, yeah. Also makes me want to go to Sydney, Australia. Yes, yeah. Because it's so beautiful. That's the season I watched. OK.
Oh, all right. Well, I didn't realize we were going to make a viewing list today, but I'm here for it. You don't know what you're going to get on Friday Chit Chat. You. You don't know what you're gonna get on Friday Chit Chat. You sure don't. Well everyone, that was your Friday Chit Chat. Yeah. We might be popping on from time to time
to chat with you. Friday Chit Chat, I like it. Yay. It's like journaling out loud. Can we hear that song again going out? Oh yeah, sure. Sure. I can't remember how we did it. Well let's see, it'll be interesting. Sure. I can't remember how we did it.
Well, let's see. It'll be interesting. Tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, Woo woo! Something like that. Perfect, love you. Maybe we'll be back another Friday, maybe with a proper song next time. See you then. Bye. Bye. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey
and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer. And our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbaco. Odyssey's executive producers are Jenna Weiss-Berman and Leah Reese-Dennis. Office Ladies is mixed and mastered by Chris Basil. Our theme song is Rubberree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.